it's hard to anticipate what might
happen on Game of Thrones especially now
that the HBO show has bypassed its
source material the eighth and final
season of Thrones is no exception to
this rule of unpredictability but the
most recent episode may have actually
spoiled the finale a melancholy song
lady Brienne Squire Podrick played by
Daniel Portman sings during a night of
the Seven Kingdoms seems to foreshadow
which person vying for the Iron Throne
will end up ruling warning spoilers
ahead The Musical moment happens while
Podrick Brienne Jaime Lannister tormund
Giantsbane Tyrion Lannister and sir
table OC worth are gathered around a
fire awaiting the arrival of the night
King and the army of the dead they drink
and reminisce on past battles on what
could be the last night of their lives
when the wine runs out
Tyrion requests someone sing a song no
one but Podrick pipes up and he begins
singing a mournful tune dance with her
go he continues with lyrics about how
Jenny couldn't remember the ghost names
but they took away her sorrow and pain
by spinning her on an old stone the song
then repeats that she never wanted to
leave this scene did more than just tug
on heartstrings as it played over shots
of our heroes in Winterfell readying
themselves for battle it evoked the mood
Pippin created when he sang the edge of
night ahead of the Battle of Askia in
The Lord of the Rings in the Song of Ice
and Fire books this tune is titled Jenny
song and is directly connected to the
series central characters and their
ancestors
Jenny song appears in the novel's is one
of the ghosts of high hearts favorite
songs which she refers to as my Jenny
song Jenny is Jenny of old stones a low
status woman who married Prince Duncan
Targaryen their union which Prince
Duncan's father King Aegon v disapproved
of spurred Prince Duncan to renounce his
claim to the Iron Throne despite being
the rightful heir in the same way Jaime
Lannister shoved bran stark out of a
Winterfell tower to protect his
incestuous relationship with his sister
Cersei Prince Duncan made the bold
decision to abdicate the throne to marry
Jenny not only does Jenny and Duncan's
story mirror that of Jaime and
it also parallels to other Targaryen Jon
Snow whose real name is Aegon Targaryen
and Daenerys in episode 2 John reveals
to his ladylove that he's actually her
nephew the son of her brother Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Stark that makes
him the rightful heir to the Iron Throne
given he's a living male descendant of
Aerys the Mad King Targaryen Podrick
singing jenny's song just before that
conversation happens might foreshadow
the events of the game of Thrones finale
John could relinquish his power to be
with Daenerys just as Prince Duncan did
it's doubtful that Podrick knew
everything about John's parentage and
the story of Jenny and Duncan when he
decided to sing the sad tune but there's
even more hidden meaning in the song
that supports the idea John may give up
the Iron Throne to be with Daenerys you
didn't tell me you were going to abandon
your crown I never wanted a crown the
ghost of high heart is thought to be the
first person who delivered the prophecy
that Eris and raela Targaryen Danny's
parents and John's grandparents could be
the ancestors of the prince that was
promised Rhaegar Danny's brother grew
obsessive over the prophecy believing he
was the prince that was promised he
thought that if he wasn't the prince one
of his children would be as vanity
fair-- notes Rhaegar may have actually
written Jenny song in the books during
the tourney of Harrenhal he plays a song
for his love
Fionna stark Jon Snow's mother it's not
out of the realm of possibility that the
tune was the one Podrick sang just after
Podrick sings Jenny song John and
Daenerys stand in front of lyanna
stark's statue in the Winterfell crypts
Daenerys says about Rhaegar everyone
told me he was decent and kind he'd like
to sing there's a chance that Jenny song
is more about the prince that was
promised prophecy than Jenny herself it
tells the story of the true born heir to
the Iron Throne giving up everything for
love
John Rhaegar son might be both the
prince that was promised and someone who
like his ancestor Duncan surrenders his
claim to kingship there really is no
telling whether Jenny song and its many
meanings reflect how the series will
conclude or whether Jon will actually
choose love over power but there's a
chance that the tune hints at what will
happen if it winds up that Jenny song is
more than a tune sung in an emotional
time at least Daniel Portman got to
prove he has the voice of an angel check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about Game
of Thrones are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]